back in january senator josh hawley of
missouri did what many democrats have
done in previous presidential election
cycles
he voted against certifying the results
pending a review
for daring to cast that vote hawley
became the most reviled man in
washington
democrats demanded his expulsion from
congress
and then holly's publisher simon
schuster suggested that he was somehow
an accessory to
violence and insurrection in a press
release simon schuster denounced
hawley and canceled his book contract
the book ironically was about the danger
of big media companies
shortly after this happened we invited
josh hawley on this show to talk about
it
the people around simon schuster are now
so crazed with ideology
that they can't bear to hear a country
view expressed i mean what what does
that
pretend for the country well i think it
really shows sucker that we're in a
period where the first amendment
values and principles of freedom of
speech also freedom of worship freedom
of religion
these things are are really under attack
by some quarters by many quarters
and again i come back to the fact that
this is something the first amendment is
something that unites us
as americans and in this time of
division
in this time of chaos we've got to we've
got to stand strong for that
simon schuster isn't the government it's
a private company but holly's point
about the first amendment is real
what good is free speech if you can't
exercise it
but for me personally what happened to
josh hawley was more than an academic
question
at the time his book was canceled i was
also under contract to produce a book
for simon
schuster a collection of magazine
journalism simon schuster was paying me
to do it but it still seemed
cowardly not to address directly what
they had just done to josh hawley
so i called the head of the company the
ceo john carp
and i told him that i thought cancelling
a book for partisan reasons was
disgusting
and wrong and that it set a very bad
precedent for american publishing
then i told him i wanted to write about
what he had done in my new book
as a kind of snapshot of what was
happening across the country
so i started to report on it in the end
i interviewed john carp and other simon
schuster executives at some length and
on the record
i asked them under what circumstances
are you willing to censor the political
views
of your authors it turned out to be an
amazing series of conversations they
were highly uncomfortable as you can
imagine but fascinating
their answers some of them honest some
of them lies revealed in the clearest
possible way how corporate america
undermines free speech and the country
itself
last week simon schuster confirmed that
they will publish my account of their
censorship
ceo john carp has said he will come on
the show to explain what he's done
and attempt to justify it we assume he
will keep his word we hope so
that book comes out the week of august
10th you can pre-order it now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else